hey everybody and welcome to an exciting
episode of wild ride with stevo
we're talking to a ufc hall
of famer today and here's a spoiler
alert
he's gonna pull out his eyeball for your
entertainment so let's
get into it ladies and gentlemen
michael bisping yeah dude
thanks steve i appreciate it buddy i
would like to introduce you to my
co-host scott randolph
what's up mr bisping what's going on
scott that much
up at the front of the van we've got the
gorgeous paul briskey hello michael how
are you he is
you are particularly gorgeous paul wow
thank you yes i mean
i've seen some handsome men in my time
but jeez louise
ufc hall of famer dude that's pretty
epic man
i love it um and and dude thank you for
doing this man it's been a
pleasure getting to know you in the the
the sort of the fight community i've
really inserted myself into it as just a
super fan
and i love to go to the fights it's
always rad to see you
and you know if there's a question
burning on my tongue that i just have to
ask right out of the gate
it's uh how does the compensation
compare between being a fighter and
calling the fights as a commentator
um i mean listen i'm not fighting so
there's way less race there's way less
work i'm not having to get punched in
the face i'm not able to break my body
down in training
uh the the pays of commentators very
good but
compared to being champion of the world
it ain't [ __ ]
but it's it's it's very good though it's
it's a very very well paid job and i'm
very grateful and very lucky to have it
and i
truly enjoy it i'm so passionate about
it uh no the pace fantastic but as i say
you know for champion of the world
it's next level right okay and and and
i i didn't mean to start off with the
particularly invasive
rude question or anything quite all
right my friend but i just wanted to
tell you i really think you're good at
it man
i absolutely love you know like what
what a treat to be able to watch the
fights get this insightful commentary
and like really have a laugh man like
you crack me up when
when uh when you're commentating and and
all yeah thanks steve
yeah of course all the ufc commentating
great man
it's just really really what an
organization man
yeah no but they're fantastic of course
well thank you very much for the kind
words i appreciate that you know and i
do try and
bring some entertainment to the table i
try to not take myself too seriously i'm
a light-hearted kind of guy and i could
like to be self-deprecating but i can't
take all the credit because the
production team
behind uh you know behind the camera if
you will backstage they do a fantastic
job they provide us
with a ton of information we sit down
with the fighters every week
we get to talk to them you know john
anik uh implemented that he spoke to the
ufc when he came over so
yeah thank you very much for the kind
words but as i say there's we get a lot
of support backstage
when did it occur to you that this could
be a like a lane for you coming out of
fighting yeah so what happened was um
obviously
you know it's well documented i have eye
issues in 2013
when uh when i got a detached retina and
then ultimately you know
i lost an eye if you will um i knew that
my days as a fighter were numbered
you know what i mean i knew that when
the cat was out of the bag
i was [ __ ] for one of a better word so
i started doing
everything i could to open as many doors
as i can because i thought at some point
soon
i'm gonna have the rug swept from under
my feet no more fight career
and what you know and then then how am i
gonna make money so i was doing
everything i could i started working on
some acting started working at fox
sports started doing analyst work
doing a podcast doing anything i could
to use my platform for one of a better
term
right i know that sounds like uh you
know a little arrogant but when you have
a platform you got to use it because
when you're a washed up
ex ex-bomb fighter nobody gives a [ __ ]
you're one of many
but while you've got that platform uh
take advantage of it so that's what i
did and i started
you know obviously doing a lot of
pre-fight work pre and post shows on fox
doing ufc tonight and then slowly but
surely
after eight goddamn years uh they gave
me a shot behind the desk
at the time i got there eventually yeah
i don't think that
anything about that sounded arrogant i
think a platform is a very you know
that's exactly what it is and um
did i hear you right when you just said
that that uh that that your detached
retina that your eye issues
that you kept secret you said when the
cat was out of the bag
yeah yeah i mean you know so you should
deep into detail
you know what i mean but but yeah yeah
you know i lost vision in the right eye
so it's a long time ago you could only
see it and you didn't tell anybody it's
crazy
only my uh close only my wife and a very
very couple of close people
you know but uh coaches fortunately
the the legal requirements to fight
you're still
classed as clinically blind so 2200
vision is still classed as clinically
blind so
uh it was a difficult one it was very
stressful because the problem is
uh every fight that you have you know
you do your training camp you fly to
wherever it is you know i used to fight
a lot internationally so let's say
i fly to australia you do an entire
training camp you fly all your team out
there obviously the training camp is
very expensive
you fly all your team you get the
flights hotels meals
and you got to pay them you know a wage
for coming and then you got to see
a local doctor at the fight the day of
the weigh-in
you know what i mean i'm always like
[ __ ] this guy might be you know
you want to be that guy pulls you from
the fight you know what i'm saying takes
a look at your eyes don't [ __ ] this
you're not fighting you shouldn't be
fighting so
that was always very stressful because
you do all that work you train your ass
off you
spend all that money and the fight might
not happen so that was always really
stressful but
fortunately never happened and i was
able to walk away on my own terms
wow so did you have to sort of trick
them that you had two functioning eyes
for a while
i cannot go into detail
now i mean i think that uh
what blows me away is that uh i when i
saw you on tmz
and and they they had you on tmz where
you actually took out your eye
and uh and i i i do not
want to ask you to do i'm not asking you
to do it we did the
this show for ufc at one point called
you have the the watch party
and and did you ever see did you see the
episode that we were on
i didn't see it no but funnily enough
i'm doing it again this weekend
how are you they've asked me to do uh uh
a twitch stream twitch is that for video
games
yeah and then instantly i love the ufc
there's nothing i won't do for them
but i'm just concerned about it because
with the watch party you've got like an
actual production crew in your house and
you know they're going to edit it
they're going to put it together it's
going to look great
but with the twitch it's just a constant
stream like you know like the whole you
kind of have to be on the whole time and
i'm just like well what if i just like
trail off and
i'm watching the fights and i'm not like
you know engaged
you know i'm nervous about not not
giving you doing it right
no i don't know i haven't i haven't uh
decided yes or no
but when we did the watch party thing
and and i haven't seen the episode
either
you did take out your eye for me and
it's
so fascinating to me that uh
i don't know if they included that in
the episode or not no no i was just
thinking you're right i did i totally
forgot all about that
obviously i uh you don't drink any more
stevo but my boxing coach does
and and i don't see him very often and i
don't drink that much these days either
contrary to popular belief
everybody thinks i'm this crazy party
animal i'm i'm really not i mean when i
was younger i was a [ __ ] nightmare
but these days i'm pretty good i'm 42
yesterday so but jason prillo came up
and i don't get to see him in a social
function very often
and the ufc they brought drinks and
brunch and food and
you know it's a watch party it's a
saturday morning i've got no work so i
had a few drinks
so i was like hold on did i i'm like oh
yeah i did yeah but
it's so it's so fascinating to me that
you've got an artificial eye
it's completely [ __ ] fake but
you you control it like uh yeah did
when did this technology become a thing
i mean
tell me about it because i you know if i
don't have it in my eye looks terrible
it looks a mess and you know i'm i'm
working on an acting career i'm very
lucky
you know i'm landing a few roles here
and there but obviously nobody wants
a [ __ ] actor with a [ __ ] up eye
looking like a cyclops or a [ __ ]
something from a horror movie unless the
character is written like that you know
what i'm saying so i'd go in for all
these auditions
and i was always so [ __ ]
self-conscious you know what i mean
that's all i was trying to do hide my
eyes stand a certain way or whatever
so i go see these opticians and they're
these specialized lenses
that had like a fake eyeball but it was
off-centered so you put it in and it
kind of looks real
but then after a while what it would do
was drift to the center and it would
look even worse
so when i'd work at fox sports all the
time i had like a little compact a
little makeup compact
and anytime we cut to b-roll or
commercial break i'd have to always pull
it out
and re-center it all the time that was
my life and um
i was going up to this uh this opticians
it was like a two-hour drive away from
me i had to go there every six weeks it
was a [ __ ] pain in the ass
and then eventually i thought to myself
i'm over this i'm just gonna get a glass
eye i'm gonna have it removed and have a
glass eye so
i made an appointment with a doctor here
in orange county
and she looked at me and she said you
don't need you know we don't want to
operate
that's always the last resort she said
there's a doctor close by
uh that can do these prosthetic lenses
turns out this place that makes them
five minutes from my house right and
they hand paint it
and match it perfectly they do a
fantastic job and uh
yeah the best three thousand dollars i
ever spent in my life
and then yeah that's what she said that
day three thousand bucks
and uh it's not the way that you picture
it either like uh
when you take it out it's it's like uh
yeah dude is he doing it
yeah oh wow absolutely
unbelievable i didn't want to ask you to
do that much yeah you're good i mean
the only reason i did it once on my
podcast hold on
believe me podcast yeah that's right i
did it on there
because the guy i do it with my co-host
he turned up and he's wearing sunglasses
in door while we're doing the show so
i'm bitching at him a little bit i'm
making fun of him
look at this rock star you know what i
mean and he starts talking [ __ ] to me
hold on a minute i've seen you showing
up at press conferences with sunglasses
on
and i said yes you're right but the
reason
i always used to wear sunglasses was
because of the eye
because i didn't want some jumped up
[ __ ] commission members saying hey
come over here let me take a look at
your eye or somebody from the ufc or
whatever
you know what i'm saying by putting
sunglasses on no one could see
[ __ ] so with the guy was making fun out
for fun out of me saying oh you used to
wear sunglasses indoor i'm like okay
this is why i used to wear [ __ ]
sunglasses so that's how that came out
and that's how
the whole thing and then of course you
know you got tmz in places like that
picking it up so
yeah the cat's out of the bag it is what
it is that's crazy
like it's just sure let me return the
favor
i got i pull out my teeth quite easily
[Laughter]
yeah was your eye looking like that
uh underneath the fake eye while you're
fighting so when you got into the ring
everybody's seen you wear glasses the
whole time up all the press conferences
and then you get in the ring
and you're fighting with that eye the
guy's like what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah but the cat was out of the bag
when i thought george saint pierre i was
training with his trainer because i was
shooting a movie in toronto and uh
richard evans said hey
call this guy jorge blanco great pad man
you know i wanted to get some working
while i was up there just
stay in shape you know she looked good
for the movie and whatnot
and as i said he was george st pierre's
coach great guy we struck up a good
friendship you know we were
hung out a few times whilst i was in
toronto and
yeah i told him you know because it's
clearly [ __ ] obvious and when you're
hitting pads and stuff the pad man kind
of needs to know
so he knew about that lo and behold i
didn't realize i'd be fighting george st
pierre the following year
so of course they know all about it and
then on the post fight celebration
george said he said oh we knew we didn't
see too well out of that eye
so that's why we targeted everything on
that side i'm like you son of a [ __ ]
but fair play because if it was me i'd
do the exact same thing so uh
once the cat was out of the bag i was
like all right i achieved what i wanted
to do
i you know i earned some money i got the
belt you know i've done it for a long
long time now's a good time to walk away
yeah dude i remember watching the uh the
the press conference stuff or the
whatever like the
yeah the press conference with with
george st pierre
and uh he might have taken care of you
in the arctic
but he could not handle you on the
microphone but the record for the record
did not [ __ ] take care of me took
care of me
with broken ribs
that's not me in my prime george
george is awesome i love georgia and
we've got we've got a good friendship
you know he came on my podcast recently
um when you're promoting a fight you
know the way i look at it
because it wasn't fabricated if you will
i didn't necessarily mean what i was
saying and i was trying to hyper fight
but also at the same time you know this
guy is trying to fight me he's going to
try and knock me out choke me out
take my world title and if i'm going to
fight someone then you know i'm going to
build a little animosity
mainly just because that's who i am and
i like to you know
if we're in this situation that's how
i'm going to handle it and it's fun
for everybody watching it helps build it
right but yeah once it's
all over me and george are fine but i
remember one time uh we were doing some
press tour i think we were at the espn
studios and whatnot
and i'm doing my usual thing i'm talking
some [ __ ] i'm insulting him you know
anything i can think of he's getting it
and then we go to the bathroom and
there's no toilet there sorry no cameras
or anything and i walk in and there's
george
and i'm having a piece and he's having a
piss and we're just talking about cars
he's oh you got a ranger over i'm like
yeah [ __ ] thing it's always breaking
down
blah blah blah blah and i got right
sorry george going back out there got to
get the game face on
i'm gonna be a dick again when we go out
there yeah i mean you say that
but i don't think that there's anything
you know
and i'm pretty i'm pretty sensitive to
it when um
like certain fighters promoting fights
they really will cross the line and a
lot of time i just don't like that i
thought that yeah
i thought it was all in good fun yeah no
for sure you know just
you know a bit of friendly ball busting
nothing too personal no family no
religion
yeah nothing like that you know just
keeping it strictly to fight stuff and
uh
making fun of his accent right
are you in luke rockhold friends now do
you guys bury the hatchet are you still
kinda
you wanna know what i have in common
with both those guys
i am a top athlete yeah
and i've been talking about going on a
big old bike ride from los angeles all
the way to san diego and ladies and
gentlemen that time has arrived
it's happening this weekend and i
couldn't be more excited
about it and i couldn't feel more
prepared
because i've got my zero sugar hydration
stocked up and ready to go
it is called element and i bet you don't
know this
but one of the biggest problems among
top athletes
is actually drinking too much water
where your electrolyte levels and your
sodium levels
drop to dangerous lows and that's what
this product is all about
it's also extremely delicious but most
importantly
it keeps your electrolyte levels your
sodium your hydration
right where you want it for serious
major workouts
and this company element has offered my
wild ride listeners
perhaps the most generous deal that i've
ever promoted
what is it they're gonna give you an
absolutely free
sample pack which comes with two pouches
of citrus flavor two pouches of
raspberry
two pouches of orange and two raw
unflavored
that is eight completely free packages
and all you have to pay is for the
shipping just five bucks and they're
going to ship it to you
now look at this deal if you don't like
it then
they're gonna give you your shipping
money back there's
absolutely nothing to lose again it's
probably the most
generous deal i've ever promoted so how
are you gonna claim this deal
you're gonna go to drink element dot com
slash stevo that's d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t
forward i'm sorry dot com forward slash
stevo
yeah and that's gonna get you this this
deal one more time
drink element.com stevo
get your free sample pack and
work out man because i'm gonna now let's
talk about luke rockhold
i i've got no problem with luke i don't
know if it's uh reciprocated that
feeling but he's down
he trains where i well where i used to
train i don't get in there very often
anymore but i'm going down there
tomorrow but yeah he's down at the
rooker training center quite a lot so
i'm
looking forward to bumping into him that
should be fun but uh yeah i'm sure
luke's a great guy
i say this all the time daniel cormier
is someone that i have
a tremendous amount of respect for he's
just a solid human being you know
as well as an insane fighter and
commentator he's just a [ __ ] good guy
and if dc has him as one of his best
friends i'm sure luke's a good person as
well you know what i'm saying
it's just that when you meet under those
circumstances where you're gonna fight
where your rivals
you know uh that's not conducive to
making friends you know what i'm saying
but i'm sure if we met
under different circumstances there's a
possibility we might have got along
yeah i'm reading your book right now
it's phenomenal when you teased it on
the believe view me podcast when i think
lewis asked you about
going to prison you're like i'd rather
not get into it so i'm like [ __ ] i got
to get this book
i have two questions about that why
didn't you read
well first to to your point of like you
know not being really friendly when you
fought rashad evans
he was not your friend and then after
you're like you want to shake my hand
now [ __ ]
like i thought that was pretty cool and
then you're talking about you you're
training with him now in like montreal
or toronto or
or you know whatever you said and then
the second is how come you didn't read
your book what it's somebody else's
voice i was expecting to hear your voice
oh
oh yeah you're talking about the audio
book yeah yeah yeah
jesus christ don't get me started on
that so i tried to do the audio book
right
and i was traveling all the time with
the ufc in regular times that's what we
do it's not always at the apex so i was
always on the road but i spoke to the
publishers i said oh listen
i do a podcast when i'm on the road so i
can show as hell do this
right i remember i was in greenville
north carolina i'm sat in the hotel room
i did all my studying for the ufc
i've got a few hours all right i'm going
to record a few chapters of the book or
a chapter or two whatever
so i sit down in the hotel room i get it
out i get the microphone and i bring it
up
[ __ ] it's a wordy book it's very very
good
i had a lot of difficulties with the
first chapter i kept tripping it up
and then i just as i started doing well
there's a knock on the door
and it's the [ __ ] major then it's
room service oh then there's someone
next door having sex i'm like for [ __ ]
sake
you know what i mean i just couldn't get
it done and in the end i said you know
what [ __ ] this someone else can do it
because i wasn't getting paid any extra
money for it so
i apologize for not doing the audio book
but i tried
and i almost had a heart attack that's
great
yeah i i read um just the first
one or two chapters of my audiobook and
um
it was just the same deal i was i had a
comedy tour and i was
you know always traveling and they just
didn't seem to
botch the scheduling of it with the
studio
but i think i'm going to do that i'm
going to go back and uh
i'm going to go back i'm going to i
think we can we can do that man
you know oh really
yeah look back because that way because
i've never even promoted the fact that
there is an audio book because it drives
me nuts that it's not me reading it
so yeah i prefer yeah i've had a few
people on twitter reach out and be like
yo what the hell
you know i was expecting you to be out
of that yeah sorry busy schedule and
whatnot and and i did try as i say just
didn't go very well
if they booked me a studio and i went in
there as a professional studio that
would have been different you know but
on this occasion as i say
in in some shitty hotel room and every
distraction under the sun
it was not easy to do yeah dude how long
you've been doing your podcast
oh about four years now i think three or
four years something like that yeah it's
a lot of fun you know it's
uh yeah sometimes we get a little
carried away with what we're talking
about and then afterwards and
oh [ __ ] did we really say that
unfortunately my co-host does not give
a [ __ ] about anything so like it gets a
little bit too personal
at times but uh people seem to enjoy it
yeah for sure it is it's great the way
that you've uh you've got the ufc and
you've got the the world of comedy
really just
intersecting it's uh and probably the
legion the legion of skanks have
probably got your back now too
yeah yeah maybe maybe but yeah no thanks
steve as i say you know i've always been
kind of a light-hearted guy so
uh a lot of people when they first meet
me to think i'm going to be this uh
stern you know maniac and and listen hey
i have my bad days
you know i'm always trying to get better
i'm trying to be a better version of
myself but generally
generally if everything's going well i'm
always a you know happy-go-lucky type of
guy
i i guess people probably ask you all
the time but being sort of like
you know at this intersection of comedy
and
and you know entertainment uh like have
you have you tried stand up you that
never thought about it
no i i haven't you know i mean i did a
one-man show
in toronto a couple of years ago um
and i guess you could say that was kind
of stand-up i walked out on a stage and
i did that and
it was about two hours and it was a sold
out crowd and people loved it got a
really really good
reception uh i was a little you know it
was my first time doing anything like
that so i definitely
[ __ ] up a couple of times you know
what i mean but uh uh everyone enjoyed
it everyone had a really good night so
i'm planning on refining that writing
out a little better you know that's my
problem i never prepare enough i'll just
wing it i'm good
i know my life i know what i'm doing but
uh yeah i'm gonna write it down properly
plan it get some multimedia get some
uh you know some extra bits to it and
take that on tour but stand up per se
no but i am going to do that sweet good
man that's cool
here's something that always interests
me about about the
fighters in general like choking people
unconscious
it's just it's it's to a lay person it's
such a
shocking and like crazy concept but to a
professional fighter
choking someone out is is really like
not not a very big deal
right it's like a party trick kind of
yeah well i mean to be honest
just fighters or jiu jitsu or anyone
that does martial arts basically yeah
not too big of a deal i mean if you're
doing jiu jitsu
you know you'll start your session
you'll do some technique whatever
at the end you roll you know you might
do five five minutes of rolling and
that's what you're trying to do you're
trying to put
your jujitsu to use you're trying to
choke people out tap them out
on bar knee bar whatever it is you're
trying to make them submit so yeah it
definitely
feels second uh second nature it doesn't
feel weird whatsoever you know and
the more you do it you know you do kind
of become desensitized to it and the
more you watch the ufc you become more
desensitized to it i remember when i
first saw the ufc i was like holy [ __ ]
because
well i saw it a long time ago i was in
new zealand in 1995 for jiu jitsu world
championships and
that was the first time i saw it then
but i'm talking about uh 2002
uh some an old trainer came to me and
said hey there's this thing called the
ufc
it's getting pretty big i think you'd be
good at it and it's all right [ __ ] it
let's go so i gave it a shot without
even
seeing it and then my wife got me uh
ultimate knockouts or ultimate
submissions or something for christmas
and i sat down with my boys
in 2002 and we watched it with beers and
they're like
this is what you're getting into michael
i'm like [ __ ] yeah
looks like it it's crazy um
like have you in uh you know like
with civilian circumstances like at a
bar or whatever like you know
house party like coffee shop they
haven't had people say
oh dude would you choke me out and and
yeah yeah it's weird i just don't
understand it you know
i don't do it i don't do it at all not
so much to choke me out more of the leg
kicks
you know a lot of people that sounds
awful there's a lot of
weird sick bastards out there they want
to be leg kicked
you know and they're going hey can you
just i mean i've had people ask me to
chill them out as well and leg kick and
i don't do it a couple of times it did
at the start and then the ufc pulled me
to one side
and i think the ufc actually sent out a
mass email to all the fighters
from now on because it's a weird like
petty thing that guys want
from now on if anybody asks you to choke
them out or kick them in the leg
do not do it because you're at serious
risk of a lawsuit because you could you
imagine if you hurt somebody
uh so yeah no i don't do that that's so
funny i was in dana white's office
and uh i was you know out there
um you know i'm gonna i asked him if i
could get a press pass and that would
sort of get me past the coveted bit
you know and so i could actually go to
the fights in person and i was like yeah
dude i'll make a rad video i'll you know
promote the ufc it'll be it'll be it'll
be cool
and uh so you know he was so nice to
invite me to his office and we hung out
for like a half an hour
and uh and i was like you know what
would make this video really perform
maybe if you choked me out and i i felt
like i i was so close i almost i had
like and
you know and he was like yeah you know
it's kind of looked like he was really
gonna do it now that i jumped up in the
air i'm like yeah
awesome and then i could see him kind of
think about it he said when we do it in
the octagon
you know at the fights tomorrow yeah
and uh i i know i know never to bug him
about that one again
uh no dave is the man though oh he is oh
my god he's my hero no he's [ __ ]
awesome he really is i've got so much
respect for the guy he's my hero
yeah i mean dana could choke you out
though have you seen the size of the
arms on the guy these days he's
[ __ ] working out like a maniac
richard you know what i get asked
constantly
is what will i kick them in the nuts oh
my god
no way yeah no way if somebody tries to
if someone did that for a laugh
yeah then we're gonna have i'm gonna
come out of retirement pretty quick
yeah like i had like i even had
i have to turn people down constantly i
said no i'm you know
i know i've i've retired from not
kicking i just don't do it anymore
and then every so often i come out of
retirement
why not hold on let me get this right so
you're kicking them in the notes
they're begging me they're they're
begging me too
holding up signs please kick me in the
nuts where we have to stop the show like
dude yeah just put the sign dude like
these impassioned pitches like dude
is there any way i could get you to kick
me in the nuts this would be my dream
what is going on in the world i mean i
know some funny times these days
you know what i mean because it's bad
news to be a man
you know what i mean especially a white
man but asking someone to kick you in
the [ __ ] balls
jesus christ get agreed especially in
australia like he would kick him in the
nuts they'd get back up and want it
again
like three or four times he kicked the
same person it's been going on for a
long time too but hey you know what
what are you gonna do i mean everybody
has their like niches it's like you get
asked to get leg kicked stone cold wants
to get arm wrestled
you get yeah do people try to fight you
michael like
you want to talk about fighting well
i've said this before and i'll say it
again
you could kick my ass but you're gonna
find it clean as a whistle
why because i wash my butt hole how
with hello tushy this is my favorite
product that i have ever promoted on the
podcast
it is a bidet which you attach to your
toilet
very simply very easily it's totally
affordable
and it really washes your butthole you
twist
the little knob and you get a refreshing
spray that just
blasts all the poop away it's like
pressure cleaning your butthole
it's better for the environment it's
better for your butthole
and when you buy it you get
a 60-day risk-free guarantee
plus a 12 month warranty and how are you
going to do that
you're going to go to hellotushy.com
stevo and that's going to get you 10 off
your order too
plus free shipping so for 10 off your
order plus
free shipping go to hellotushy.com
stevo and your butthole is going to
thank you trust me
it's my favorite product and i say that
proudly
now let's talk about asking michael
bisping to fight
for the most part people are cool you
know what i mean certainly you know i've
certainly had once or twice
over the years i've had a couple of
[ __ ] i was in this place once in
manchester and like some gang lads
came in and now i knew there was going
to be an issue there because they don't
fight with the fists you know what i
mean it was all knives and guns i was
like oh [ __ ] here we go
uh but uh generally people are okay i'm
tough guys
you know tough guys are dormant security
they know they watch and they always
have respect
so as i say generally for the most part
people just come up and say hey what's
up man respect
you know whatever handshake quick
picture whatever yeah
and and i don't really put myself in
those situations to be honest
anyway so uh i'm pretty good i mean when
i was a kid yeah i was a bit of a
[ __ ] i was always
always getting in trouble but yeah i i
learned my lesson the hard way
the leg kick thing man it seems so so
weird to me
like uh the people asking for a leg kick
and uh particularly this past weekend
i i i heard you saying on the the you
you do you really believe that leg calf
kicks should become illegal or you're
just
no no i don't know i was just joking
definitely changing they're
so effective that they're having such a
major impact on nearly every single
fight now
you know so no i was just kind of
kidding because it is now becoming the
ultimate calf kicking championship
if you start dropping those kicks the
other guys [ __ ]
uh so no no i was absolutely kidding i
think it's a tremendous evolution in the
sport and it's a new weapon
that i feel that again as the sport
evolves a little more they're going to
come they're going to find a really good
way of countering them
because a typical leg kick you you block
it you check it you lift your leg up
and you kind of block it with the top of
your shin or your knee
and that really hurts the other person
if you're going up against a really good
kicker
if you check that first leg kick
generally they don't throw another one
because you can break their legs right
it really really hurts with a calf kick
you can't really block it the same way
you've just got to not be there you got
to lift it up right you could have good
timing good reflexes but
but yeah no i think they're a fantastic
weapon it was just
just a bit of a joke sure and that's the
thing about it too is that you can
throw the calf kick without really like
putting yourself
in the pocket in any kind of danger you
know like it's just kind of there and
yeah
yeah yeah because obviously the legs are
longer than your the arms
you know what i mean so kicks you can
land further away and a calf kick
because it doesn't come up as high
because you always want to look your
opponent in the eye
you know what i'm saying you never look
at where you're going to throw a punch
or a kick because it gives it away
so or you look at the chest you look
there you know sometimes it gets a
little weird if you look at them in the
eye the whole time
you know i look at the chest i'm like
okay i'm not gonna make out afterwards
buddy
so i look at the chest and and if you're
looking at the chest or the eyes you
don't really see the calf kick because
it's so low
you know what i'm saying so it is hard
to defend for that to defend for that
reason
yeah the ufc has been around for 25
years how how is the calf kick
now becoming popular like a year and a
half ago like how did they not think to
kick that calf
the last 23 years it's a really good
question because it seems so obvious
you know i'm kicking the leg i'm kicking
the thigh i'm kicking the body i'm
kicking the head
uh it just yeah it just never really
caught on i'm sure some people have been
doing it for a long time i'm sure
certain martial arts i've done it for a
long time but it just wasn't popular in
the ufc
and i've i've lived out in thailand you
know for many months and and trained out
there extensively and was never
shown a calf kick or anything like that
i'm glad they weren't around when i was
fighting because they look like they
[ __ ] suck
you know what i mean you see the calf
swell up and people
get taken clean off their feet uh but as
i said they weren't around in my day and
i'm very grateful yeah in the last
year there's been like three tkos bites
strictly calf kick
wow yeah it's wild it really is it looks
like it hurts like hell because as i say
some people
i forget which one it was saturday night
but dustin jacoby he was the first
fighter of the
uh on the prelims in his last fight he
fought a guy called justin ladet a very
very good boxer
and he just calf kicked him about four
times in a row and that's it he was done
he was on the floor
he managed to get back up but he got up
so so difficultly because of the damage
he just got dropped again when he got
back up but it was all set up from the
calf king so uh
yeah they are they are they're taking
over the sport
when you're not calling a fight or
otherwise working
at the ufc are you just sitting on the
sofa watching the fights as a fan
yeah pretty much pretty much i'm sitting
at home on twitter trying to not talk
too much [ __ ] because i'm very sarcastic
so i'm always making jokes and i think
oh hold on maybe the sarcasm doesn't
cross over in that so
you know but yeah generally i'm sat at
home watching the fight obviously
as a commentator you know what i mean
it's important that i do
i need to don't fight his history i need
to know the
the prelim guys you know and i need to
know their history and their backstory
so when you commentate in a fight
there's so much work goes into it i
don't just show up
on saturday and and start calling the
fights as i said before we have a
fighter meeting on the wednesday or the
thursday that takes a few hours
and then every fight on the card you
know i put about two
two hours research into each fighter so
it takes a full week
because you gotta give the the guy on
the prelims having his first fight in
the ufc
on the first fight of the night i try to
give them just as much respect
and and focus as the guy in the main
event you know because they're making
the same sacrifice
they're putting everything into it
they're putting their life on the line
essentially going out there
so you can't think oh he's the first guy
in the prelims [ __ ] him i just look at
his record and whatnot you know so
there's a tremendous amount of uh of
research goes into it so yeah so when
i'm sitting at home
same thing i'm watching the prelims i'm
doing all that stuff i'm taking mental
notes
yeah and the contender series as well i
mean what a
it's uh a lot of fun man um
so when uh when you started in the ufc
of course you could have all these logos
all over your
your shorts like all that you know it's
great you get
all this money from sponsors and then
all of a sudden that goes away because
there's the the reebok deal and and and
you're not even getting any money from
the reebok deal like was that like
i asked this to i i asked ronda rousey
and she was like yeah well you know like
look at the nba look at you know do they
have their own little sponsors all over
the uniform like no this was the ufc
becoming legitimate
and i thought that was an interesting
take but part of me
wants the fighters to be able to you
know get [ __ ] paid you know
yeah yeah no no i hear what you're
saying and certainly
there was a booming period where with
the sponsors you know
you were making a lot of money uh but
then it kind of calmed down a little to
be honest and and the
the ass kind of fell out of that market
i don't know why but there wasn't as
much money to be earned i think maybe
got oversaturated or whatever
and when the reebok deal came in there
was a tiered system and i was lucky
because
i was in the top tier you know what i
mean it was based on the number of
fights that you had and i
you know i'd had many many fights in the
organization so i was lucky
i started at the top tier and yeah
listen there was definitely still
a drop in money i can't lie you know
what i mean but i will say this as well
i actually said it to dana at least now
but we always get paid
because a lot of these companies you
have shorts all over your patches or
whatever and you'd have little
arrangements that your manager
gets for you good luck getting paid you
know the next six months after the fire
right you're chasing them up you're
going chase sending emails phone calls
and a lot of them just don't pay
you know one company that i was with um
[ __ ] them yeah fear the fighter never
paid me for a full year
and that was prior to the reebok deal i
could have gone with anybody do you know
what i mean
so um yeah you know at least this way
you were guaranteed to get your money
good cool hey can you explain something
to to me and maybe probably
90 of america is a scouser
a scouser is a fighter from liverpool
so do they have to be born in liverpool
like are you considered a scouser
no no no i was born in cyprus right
she's a an island in the mediterranean
but it was on a british army base so on
british soil no you don't have to be a
fighter a scouser is just somebody from
liverpool
you're from liverpool you're a scouser
and they all [ __ ] talk like this mate
so good [ __ ] luck understanding a
[ __ ] word when you get there
you won't understand the [ __ ] words
right they all talk like that it's hard
to understand
um some of the funniest funniest people
ever the scars is that they they
we call it taking the piss they take the
piss like no others they got banter
for days and it's also a very very tough
city as well so yeah
if you're a scouser you're from
liverpool that's it and darren tell us
from liverpool
yeah yeah he's a scouser and he's
hilarious as well
he was welterweight then he went up to
middleweight so that was it wouldn't
have ever been a fight for you
yeah no he was welterweight and yeah he
came up to middleweight and i wish him
all the best but uh he's got a good
chance of being a champion yeah no
different generations different
generations you know what i mean i paved
the way for darren without
darren you know what i'm saying i'm only
messing of course no
darren's awesome we're good friends and
uh hopefully see him become the champion
one day
yeah it's interesting to uh hearing in
your book you talk about weight cuts and
you're like oh [ __ ]
you know you're eating chinese food two
hours before your weight cut like
doing that yourself back in the day i
mean how how much different is it
than nowadays and there's like a science
to cutting weight right
yeah you know it's funny because my wife
bought me a book
yesterday and uh i was reading it and
it's about this boxer and it was set in
like the 1800s and i'm reading the book
and even in there
they're talking about how this one guy
was training too hard for this fight
and that is and i i stopped i turned to
my wife i said look at this i said in
the 1800s they knew
about overtraining right i said this
[ __ ] team that i was with in england
the training schedule that i used to be
on was just ridiculous and they knew
nothing about nutrition
or weight cuts or anything like that you
know and i would i would push myself
into a grave
in training i trained so hard it was
ridiculous and
one of the things was the the the weight
cuts so i knew nothing of cutting weight
and on when i was a light heavyweight i
was weighing
205 pounds and i was fighting rashad
evans
and he was in the sauna killing himself
cutting 20 pounds or whatever
to make 205 pounds and the team that i
was with they all wanted to eat chinese
food which is the worst food ever to eat
the day before a [ __ ] way
a fight but that's what they wanted to
eat so i was with them and i'm
i'm [ __ ] drinking sprite and eating
noodles you know
and i'm like i don't think i'm making
the same sacrifices rashad here
you know what i mean he's in the sauna
killing himself i'm having [ __ ]
chicken charmaine
that's right you know what i mean i'm
like so after that fight i lost it
it was a close fight but i lost it so i
went down to
middleweight after that one yeah so
so uh now what about like
merch did do you have like did you have
like when you're
once the reebok deal comes in or like or
you know the whole time
there's the ufc merch and then you have
your own merch as well that you sell
yourself
i do not no no i've never ever done any
merch or anything yeah i'm uh
uh i wish i did and i'm sure
there is some out there because i've
looked online i can go buy it
from one of many mickey mouse
[ __ ]
but it's got nothing to listen mate it's
hard enough for me to get onto a podcast
i do a podcast twice a week and i
commentate the ufc you know what i mean
other than that i don't have
you know i've got a lot of free time on
my hands and just doing that is too much
you know what i'm saying so [ __ ]
organizing merch yeah i'm the wrong man
for the job
man i i think we could help you out
there man like
i i've been pretty active with selling
merch
over the years and uh and then and then
more recently we decided that uh you
know
not to farm out our fulfillment of all
of our orders to some
third-party 3pl fulfillment center we
went ahead and got a warehouse and
and uh fulfill all our own orders and we
do it pretty simple
pretty easy if if you wanted to fire up
a shopify store and start selling some
stuff
we'll hook you up and on top of that you
get a hundred percent of all your
revenue all we need to do is just
build in a handling fee for the shipping
oh no of course of course you know it's
funny because i have a friend of mine
that owns a brand called violent
gentleman and he's doing some podcast
marriage
uh so we're about to start that scene
but yeah some personal merch
definitely steve let's talk i mean yeah
and whether it's us whether it's not i
mean who cares dude yeah
i just recommend getting in the game
because uh it's pretty remarkable
like when you stick with it when you
know after a while like it becomes like
a pretty
pretty substantial it's funny you say
that because the other day
you know everybody spends too much time
on social media
the other day i'm looking and i see max
holloway's and i was just curious
you know you click on his profile see
how many followers he's got now because
i thought
he's super successful i guarantee his
followers are going up and i looked and
it was i forget three four million or
something i'm like holy [ __ ] good for
him
and then you swipe to the the left or
right whatever it is and then it takes
you to a shop
yeah on instagram and i'm like what the
[ __ ] i am missing a trick
i have not done this ever so it's funny
you mentioned that i was just thinking
about it the other day
yeah i mean either either way man i
recommend getting into it
and how about max holloway got
essentially no credit
maybe he did but but not widely enough
for starting that whole bottle cop
bottle cap challenge
i saw that he did it he was absolutely
him
who [ __ ] started it like he was the
very first one and he was the only one
where the the cap stayed on the bottle
everybody else it was just an exercise
and knocking the [ __ ] cap off the
bottle
he's the only one who kept it on that
was the whole point
and uh daniel's genius man i'm the only
one who did the bottle cap challenge
with nothing but my penis
are you one of those guys that goes in
for these stupid challenges you know
what i mean like there's one recently
the silhouette
or like the girls with their normal
garden and they put their hair and then
they move it and they're all looking
sexy i'm like
[ __ ] off okay go and get your attention
somewhere else i don't want to see it
okay keep this to pictures of your kids
or whatever [ __ ] off for your stupid
challenges right i think i've done it
twice
and only to take the piss like when i
did the when i did the bottle cap
challenge with my dick
and uh i feel the water challenge with
the yeah there's the als water challenge
i forget how i was making fun of that
but uh that took the piss out of that
too
yeah i don't know i'm not too too big
into jumping on on stuff like that
yeah yeah for max holloway i i think
i think he'd probably prefer the credit
of being the best boxer in the ufc as he
said in his last fight
right yeah that was that was an
unbelievable against calvin cater
jesus it was i mean that it was
reminiscent of uh the way izzy took
apart costa yeah i mean just no no
what you just mentioned that's why i'm
looking forward to this weekend so much
because yamblahovic
is an absolute monster you know and he's
got massive knockout power great
wrestling
and adasanya we all know how good he is
i mean what he did to coaster i mean
that was an absolute masterpiece just
picked him apart and just destroyed him
really but
coaster was he was a little intimidated
isn't going to be intimidated i can't
see that man being intimidated just
knocked out dominic reyes knocked out
rock hall knocked out
uh many many people
uh corey anderson corey anderson exactly
yeah
yeah yeah so yeah that's it's a really
interesting stylistic matchup because
somebody like israel ladasana
is like an anderson silva they're a
kicker and they use their reach in their
range right
but if you get in their face that kind
of nullifies that
that advantage that they have you know
so they always say crowd a kicker
so you got to go forward and put them on
their back foot if you allow somebody
like anderson to stand in the middle of
the octagon
control the range and control the
octagon you're always going to have a
tough time but if you can put them on
the back foot
it gets a lot easier now of course
easier said than done because you're
going to walk through strikes you've got
to use
faints and head movement to get on the
inside all right if you can do that
that's the way you beat somebody like
that so that's why this weekend's going
to be a ridiculous fight i
i don't think that that's going to be
the the solution to the problem because
you know i look at the way that whitaker
fought izzy and whitaker came forward
and got knocked the [ __ ] out whitaker
whitaker had a [ __ ] awful fight there
steve oh
you leave the fight analysis to me i'll
leave the ball kicking to you
trust me that is the way to beat him
robert whittaker
i'm a big fan of robert he's a great guy
i've got so much respect for him
but that night against israel alasana he
was [ __ ]
the reason he because you're right he
tried to go forward but what he did was
he was leaping with a left hook he was
leaping in that's not how you do you got
to walk them down you got to use head
movements
faints whatever draw a reaction out of
your opponent so then when they throw
and you're not there when the arm comes
back that's when you go in
you don't just jump in sloppy from a
distance like whitaker was doing
but as i said as i said you you're new
to this steve no problem
let me ask you let me ask you this and
it's not like technical
fight but but but i see uh
people accusing uh both
jon jones and israel adesanya of
avoiding each other like like they're
saying as soon as jon jones decided
i'm going up to heavyweight then izzy
came up to 205
and and i think that there's some other
version of it where uh
where john jones was was uh avoiding
izzy like
i don't know there's no way i mean
there's always stupid theories like that
floating about and honestly both of them
are kind of laughable if you really
break it down because for jon jones
he was in the light heavyweight division
for the longest time a multijet
multi-generations is what he took out of
champions and contenders
one after the other see when you're the
champion of the world you're
always fighting the next best guy in the
world and that guy
being becoming the champ when you're
fighting for the title for the first
time you got an opportunity to change
your life
so you know every single person that is
fighting they're they're
leaving no stone unturned they're doing
everything they can in training camp
they're making all the sacrifices
they're spending money on on the rehab
and ev the recovery
everything they can do to be the best
version to become the champion of the
world
and john jones took out as i said
generations of fighters like that one
after the other
so to suggest that he's scared of a
middleweight coming up is disrespectful
and for alasana undefeated beating
everybody
right and when you go up to another
weight class to fight jon jones
or he's fighting yamblahovic now he's
got nothing to lose
you know if he loses that fight he's
still the champion of the world at 185
and you get credit for being a badass
and trying to take on the bigger
champion
so again that that that theory for
alasagne doesn't really hold any water
either
but still that's what people do they go
out there they make these theories
people that fight in the ufc they're not
scared of the other person you know
they look they might look at a match up
and think that's a bad matchup
this is a good matchup but scared i
don't think that's ever the right word
to use
right i think that that sounds perfectly
fair and and is he's a big favorite
over over yon yeah absolutely
and i see why 20 you know you know 20 an
hour against the opposition that is beat
that's an incredibly hard
thing to do uh and i'm i'm not making a
prediction because i'm working the fight
but
i think it's a hard fight for is it i
also think it's a tremendously tough
fight for yamborhovic you know both of
them
have got a really tough fight on the
hands uh if if you look at the skill
sets izzy's got the speed
he's got the the technique he's got the
finesse he's got the swag he's got all
that type of stuff on the flip side
you've got behovic he's not as fast but
he's a bigger guy he's a stronger guy
and he hits hard
and he does have an ability of finding
the mark as
so when you break it down like that yeah
i think izzy has the advantage i think
he's probably correctly the betting
favorite but
it's not going to be easy it's not going
to be easy at all and if you can put him
on the back foot you can get him up
against the fence
see that's why backing people up against
the fence is so important because if
you're in the middle of the octagon if
you're swinging punches
well they can just back up right but
when you back them up against the fence
they can't back up any further they've
got nowhere to [ __ ] go and if you
trap them against the fence and then you
could unleash
well then you got a problem wow any
chance that uh
megan anderson wins against nunes
nobody beats nina's right nobody and
then uh and then
yon and all joe i'm guessing john's
probably a big favorite
i i haven't seen the odds yet i'm
working this one for espn this week so i
gotta i better get my [ __ ] together
but um alger man's such a good wrestler
you know and
any time you're a really really good
wrestler like that it's such a great
skill to have
you know so peorian not as good a
wrestler
let's see how his takedown defenses if
the fight stays on the feet
the yan's tough as hell on the feet you
know but but algiem isn't going to come
in there
and just try and stand with him he's
going to mix things up he's going to
stand and he's going to shoot takedowns
then he's going to go back to the strike
and then he's going to go back to the
takedowns
he's going to mix things up nicely so i
think that's going to be a really
competitive
fight dude i can't even wait anything
that we can promote for you
oh no no no i'm good i'm good i mean
obviously we've got the podcast believe
you me but yeah
you know i'm not one of those you know
whether oh give me a follow on instagram
or twitter catch me on there as well
yeah i always like my oh god no
i'm good i'm good well i love that i
love that we follow each other on
instagram sometimes i'll see oh mike
bisping did he liked my little post and
and oh yeah
it's always nice isn't it when somebody
you know that you know likes it you know
i see a couple sometimes like oh [ __ ]
hey babe look you just like this
you know i only wrote my podcast what's
he called you plays thor what's his name
uh chris hemsworth yeah chris ends with
so uh
we weren't talking [ __ ] but he was
hitting pad so we critiqued his [ __ ]
striking on the pads and stuff like that
and we were having a laugh because we
always do
and if you've got a sense of humor it's
not insulting if you haven't got a sense
of humor
you might find out our podcast insulted
because but we're always just having fun
it doesn't come from a bad place
so we're having i'm like you know
mocking it a little bit and making fun
of it and i'm just
having a laugh and i posted that clip on
youtube
and i didn't realize chris hemsworth
follows me and i'm like
oh [ __ ] when i saw it you know what i
mean but as i say all good nature
and he had a good sense of humor about
it yeah yeah no he liked it
that's great um and uh what
the [ __ ] i was gonna say with the kid
that we got the believe you meek podcast
and uh yeah [ __ ] a man it's it's uh
in your book documentary
i've got a documentary coming out soon
that i'm really really excited about
we're just that's just
about to uh be announced but we we were
working on that for about three years so
i'm very excited because i love star
power and that we've got vin diesel on
there we've got mickey rourke
got a bunch of ufc talent as well dana
daniel cormier those guys so uh yeah
that comes out a couple of months so
keep an eye out for it
yeah excellent man and dude i i owe you
a podcast too that
at one point um at one point there was a
thing with it
and there's a little bit of footage
circling around where jon jones had
taken a hammer to my ear and you're like
all right
and i was playing koi about it because
it's for a project that that's really in
its infancy and it's going to be way
down the road and i was like oh i don't
want to
i don't really want to talk about that
too much but uh but yeah let's let's set
a time and i'll come on your podcast uh
you know talk about whatever the [ __ ]
you want would love that
would absolutely love that so thanks
steve i appreciate it bud all right well
listen guys nice talking to you really
appreciate it always a pleasure steven i
just want to say
been a massive fan been a massive fan
for years absolutely love the jackass of
course because
the jackass i absolutely love jackass i
mean [ __ ] i'm sounding like a boomer
there
i really enjoy uh the jackass no i
really [ __ ] loved it it was awesome
hilarious new one coming out dude
there's gonna be a jackass for coming
out scheduled for uh
september of of this year oh no way
oh good for you congratulations picked
up some new hardware
some new how scars that i mean come on i
mean so
all those stuff those stunts that you do
you do for real right
there's no trickery to it not none
whatsoever and what
was schedule a time on your podcast i'll
i'll tell you whatever you want to know
tell me all about it all right then
fellas well until then be well
take care and enjoy the fights this
weekend last question
it's got to be michael bisping not mike
bisping right like on the
on the the thumbnail on the oh well
my instagram is my baseball but mike
michael mick whatever
they all work let's see now people call
me mike
and the people where i come where i come
from i come from this small tiny town in
the northwest of england
and they're like he calls himself mike
these days
did he used to call him he's always
changed he calls himself mike
excuse me mike i got a lot of [ __ ] for
that i was like well
it's my name it is my name no one says
nick
you know so uh mike michael mick
[ __ ] that mummy works as well so
whichever one you wanted people would
click it
people would click it if that was the
time
that was a popular one hey man thank you
so much dude
anytime steve thank you thank you thank
you nice to see you talking to you man
what a good time man i really like
michael bisping
and uh dude i just realized that i'm
gonna be riding my bicycle maybe
during these fights this weekend this
card is just too much
i've got to get to my destination in san
diego
here by what 3 p.m on saturday when the
prelims start
oh i'm going to be hustling dude 100
miles how many it's like
probably going to be more like 110 miles
that i'm gonna have to ride
within 24 hours doesn't seem too bad
can't wait to let you guys know how it
goes and uh
as always man the people who stick
around thank you so much
i do want to show off this killer
sweatshirt i'm wearing
you can get one at stevo.com but hey man
you guys
most important have a great weekend and
thank you for watching
yeah dude